now then he's the man who informed the
Nation about perhaps one of the stranger
symptoms of kobit 19 the loss of smell
and taste but now epidemiologist Tim
Spector has turned his attention to gut
health and will soon be releasing his
latest book called food for life and he
joins me now Professor to inspector very
good morning to you thanks so much for
talking to us a lot of people at this
time of year think about their diet
don't they they may have had a
particularly indulgent Christmas they
may feel they want to lose a bit of
weight they may just want to feel
healthier going into the new year so to
those people now what would your advice
be
um the advice that we have and also
um the company Zoe behind the the covet
app and the the Zoe Health app is is
that we shouldn't be making dramatic
decisions now that are going to be short
lasting and over ambitious and lead to
failure so that we should be looking at
changes to our diet that are going to be
sustainable long-lasting and uh that are
Journey going to be good and healthy for
our gut and not try and do things like a
crash diet or calorie counting that have
been shown scientifically not to work so
it's more about
um getting resolutions that are small
little nudges little changes that really
can improve your diet
um in this way and uh there's the Zoe
team uh have got together uh a habit
tracking app the same one that is still
tracking covert and flu at the moment to
help people make these changes and they
can download that free app if they want
but the key really is yes do make some
changes but
um I think an easy way to think about
this is if you think about improving
your gut health over the next year
um with five simple tips you can really
make big improvements to your General
Health and uh the five the five tips to
remember are 8 30 different plants a
week that includes nuts seeds herbs and
spices trying to eat the rainbows lots
of colorful vegetables and plants have
regular fermented foods uh every day in
small amounts is really important give
your gut a rest so try and eat in a
smaller eating window so your your gut
microbes get a break and your you have
at least 12 to 14 hours where they're
not eating or doing things they can rest
and finally reduce your dependency on
Ultra processed foods that we know make
you hungrier and it's only bad for your
gut microbes and your metabolism so I
think it's it's about changing the
mindset avoiding things like calorie
controlled diets crash diets you know
doing things to extreme levels that you
can't support it's it's about making
little changes that last you the year
can you explain why good gut health
means good overall health
because that your gut uh microbes this
community have got microbes the
microbiome is actually inherently linked
to your immune system and it's like a
little mini Pharmacy all these these
bugs are producing chemicals that
um
in a way communicate with your immune
system most of which is in your gut and
it's that immune system that fights
covid fights flu but also fights aging
cancer and has a key role in heart
disease and dampening down inflammation
so we know that your gut microbes now
are really a sort of newly discovered
organ that are pretty vital for your
body and that's why we're start we're
changing our mind about nutrition so
rather than it just being fuel we really
think of it as a way of feeding this
this new organ in our bodies so that we
have the best defenses uh for health and
for you know prevent rapid aging
absolutely fascinating staff I've
started drinking kombucha which is very
nice I'm hoping that's one of the things
that you'd approve of yeah yeah
absolutely with the 5Ks you want to
remember it uh so you've got uh kefir
which is fermented milk kombucha is
fermented tea uh you've got
um uh Kraut which is like sauerkraut uh
and you've got kimchi which is sort of
Korean chilies and pickles
um and if you remember those you know
you're going to be doing pretty well so
anyway
increase my shopping list before we let
you go um Tim Spector I do want to ask
you about covid-19 because you've done
so much studying of it and there is a
new variant that seems to be sweeping
across the U.S should we be worried
about that do you think
um slightly but not I think some of the
hype about it has been uh exaggerated
this is the the new Omicron variant the
xbb and it's only about four percent in
the UK so it hasn't had a big impact
here and
um we're not luckily at the moment we're
seeing according to the Zoe app uh we're
now seeing a clear drop in covert cases
and in flu and cold cases so in a way uh
we might have been lucky with the timing
of this that we're actually coming out
and it's less likely that any new
variant is going to have a Major Impact
but like all of these variants it's
really important that we continue to
monitor it and we are doing that with
the uh with the Zoe app as we see where
the symptoms have changed so far we're
not seeing any change in symptoms it's
still the cold-like symptoms the sore
throat that is that is up on our list
but uh good to remain Vigilant but I
don't think uh real cause for concern at
the moment for those people who are
worried uh you know it's uh there's lots
of other things to worry about though
oh yes well indeed and sadly we don't
have the time to go into those right now
but Professor Tim inspector thanks very
much indeed for your time this morning
really interesting stuff we appreciate
it